well brian when will i get the vaccine
that is a question we keep getting here
in our eight news now newsroom so
today the southern nevada health
district talked about the distribution
plan
moving forward sally jaramillo joins us
now from our newsroom and sally
tier four is when a majority of the
public will be getting their
opportunity to get the vaccine we need
to remind viewers that we're still on
tier one
denise tier four is still several months
off tier two
should begin by february as of yesterday
21 000 coded vaccines both from pfizer
and moderna
have been administered in clark county
to those in tier one
that includes healthcare workers and
nursing homes to date the health
health district has received about 70
000 tier 1 vaccines
joanne rupert director of clinical
services explains the tears especially
regarding our senior population
the tears never really get finished so
to speak
but we move into the next tier as we
offer vaccine
for the first group right so 75 and up
is a diverse group as
any other group um some are healthier
than others
some live in you know congregate
settings
some do not so it's going to have to be
a multi-um
approach to this uh to
meeting those needs this week tier one
distribution continues as well as
planning for future vaccinations
as for those in tier 2 that includes
essential retail workers education
and child care staff essential public
transportation
just to name a few tier 3 elderly
nevadans age 65 plus tier 4
healthy people for hospital personnel
already vaccinated in december
the second dose will be administered
starting this week reporting live in the
newsroom sally jaramillo 8 news now